So I sort of don't even know how to introduce
this first story today. Um, except I guess
to just start with the [inaudible], the fact
a photographer caught a picture of Donald
Trump's, uh, handwritten notes that he had
made. Um, right after he finished giving,
just to completely off the rails unhinged
press conference on Monday. Uh, and in the
handwritten notes, which were photographed,
Trump had the terrorist group, Al Qaeda written
as a l c a I d a all one word, more like a
superfood berry of some kind then the terrorist
group. And right away when the world express
concern that the guys clueless the usual defenders
came out of the woodwork and said, listen,
just because you can't spell it doesn't mean
you can't think he could be incorrectly spelling
really good ideas. It's ablest to criticize
the fact that he seems unable to spell, which
is sort of extra funny because when you hear
from people who seem to have no concerned
about disabled rights, start to say, you're
being mean to Trump and enable us to weigh
because the guy can't spell.
Uh, that's weird. And it's also weird because
it implies that Trump has some kind of cognitive
disability, which those same people have to
date. Denied is the case. Uh, but this has
become popular recently. I saw some people
recently explaining or attempting to explain,
uh, you know, when you go online and someone
says your instead of you apostrophe Ari, uh,
it's totally irrelevant. Uh, whether they
spelled something correctly or whether they
use the right version of your or your, uh,
they might just process information differently.
They could still have really good ideas. These
are still people who we should be turning
to when it comes to, uh, political ideas and
how the country should be organized or whatever.
There's no connection between their spelling
and grammar and anything else. The thing is,
this is not the case for Donald Trump. Okay.
There are certainly people that we could identify
and say, Hey, you know what, uh, they have
dyslexia and here's how this is reflected.
But it really doesn't seem to influence their
ability to think. It's no indication of the
fact that they are limited or ignorant or
whatever else. This is not some mere isolated
spelling mistake with Donald Trump. The press
conference itself was off the rails. The ideas
that Trump is spouses are off the rails. He
has demonstrated himself to be ignorant to
foreign and domestic policy and economic policy
and, and, and so many other things. And it
turns out that he also doesn't seem to know
that al-Qaida a l hyphen Q, a e d a is not
spelled ALC a I. D a this is red alert in
sanity for a president of the United States.
Now, I thought it was actually a joke when
I saw this. I thought that this was some kind
of Photoshop thing. Uh, I, I, I truly didn't
believe that Donald Trump had written down
what looks like Al Syeda on a piece of paper
as his notes.
But it is real. And this is the press conference
in which Donald Trump said that for a ethnically
minority congress, women should go back to
where they originally came from, their original
countries for which he was ridiculed worldwide.
And this is all made much worse when you realize
that Donald Trump's absurd and erratic comments
weren't actually off the cuff. We often say
Trump should really stick to his notes or
the script or the teleprompter that he criticized
Barack Obama for using, but now relies on
himself because if he strays from it, if he
goes off the cuff, he goes off the rails.
He had these ideas in his notes, not only
Al Sayeda, but also stuff about these people
and socialism and whatever else, and I hate
to bring this up again only because it's so
upsetting to imagine that this is what's going
on. Obviously this is renewing fears and concerns
about dementia or cognitive decline in Donald
Trump.
Yeah, Trump might just be a bad speller in
addition to being completely ignorant and
narcissistic and xenophobic and racist and
a sexual predator, but once again, we do have
to confront the possibility that there's cognitive
decline here and every new glimpse we get
into the mind of Donald Trump is only increasing
the concerns that this is more than just a
guy who can't spell and has bad ideas. This
is a story about winning the birth lottery.
Okay? Trump is a guy who, if he were not the
son of a millionaire who gave Trump a small
loan of 1 million bucks to start a real estate
business would be the guy ranting about Jesus
on the subway platform. Okay? Were it not
for being the CEO his entire life? Like if
Trump actually had to work somewhere like
a normal employee, his personality combined
with his ignorance, would make him unable
to hold a job in any other country.
By the way, Trump would only be a billionaire
real estate dude. He would not have become
president of the United States. Here in the
United States. We have this sort of special
privilege, as some might call it a, and I'm
using that term sarcastically. We have the
special privilege of having 60 million people
who thought this was a good idea when they
voted back in November of 2016 or at least
a better idea than Hillary Clinton. So this
is a combination. This is a rare combination
that we have of someone who, to go back to
the beginning of the story. Yes. Can't spell
and is a narcissist, xenophobic, ignorant,
whatever, who also only even had the possibility
of running for president because of winning
the birth lottery in the United States and
had the benefit of tens of millions of ignorant
people in the United States who thought it
was a good idea to vote for him.
It really takes, you know, we talk about the
multiverse theories, a, a multiverse hypotheses
about, um, uh, you can imagine that there
are an infinite number of additional universes
in which everything is possible, where you
are king of the United States and whatever
else. We seem to be in one of those wacky
scenarios where the stars have aligned so
to speak, and Donald Trump has been able to
become president of the United States and
it's bad. I'm glad that foreign leaders are
finally saying the extent to which it's bad
and they recognize it's bad. Now we just have
to make
the right decision. In November of 2020